la question orale numéro 470 de madame
joëlle garriaud-maylam à monsieur le
ministre chargé de l'économie sociale et
solidaire et de la consommation oui
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre la numérisation des livres
constituent une chance unique pour leur
diffusion à l'international
permettant ainsi de dépasser le problème
des coûts et des modalités de leur
acheminement elle est également une
chance pour la francophonie beaucoup de
pays francophones ou souhaitant le
devenir n'ayant pas la chance d'avoir
maillage de librairies ou de
bibliothèque avec des livres français
pourtant l'essentiel de la littérature
française récente ne peut être achetés
en ligne par des consommateurs situés à
l'étranger de nombreux distributeurs
exige en effet une carte bleue française
ou limitent les possibilités d'achat aux
clients utilisant un terminal dont
l'adresse ip est situé en france
cette situation très pénalisante pour
les français vivant à l'étranger
constitue aussi un frein important au
rayonnement de notre langue et de notre
culture
bien au delà du problème des droits des
consommateurs les enjeux sont ceux de la
promotion de la francophonie et de la
vitalité de notre commerce international
en matière littéraire et culturel
ce blocage pose aussi la question de
l'accessibilité pour les consommateurs
européens à l'ensemble des offres
proposées dans les autres pays clé de
voûte du marché unique à ce propos la
ministre du commerce extérieur nicole
bricq m'avait indiqué en réponse à une
de mes questions écrites il ya quelques
mois que cette question de la
discrimination fondée sur l'âge hall aux
localisations de l'adresse ip était
discutée dans le cadre des travaux
européens de la directive 2006 123 ce je
souhaiterais donc connaître l'état
d'avancement de ces négociations il
serait également intéressant monsieur le
ministre de savoir si d'autres états
européens ont trouvé une solution c'est
quand est ce problème
autre point délicat la loi relative au
prix unique du livre numérique dispose
que je cite le régime du prix unique est
valable uniquement pour les acheteurs
situés en france
quelle interprétation de cet article est
elle faite pour la vente de livres
numériques à des clients situés à
l'étranger il semblerait en effet
logique que ceux ci est taxé aux ebooks
au même tarif que pour les consommateurs
situés en france puisqu'il n'ya pas de
frais de transport ou de douane j'ai
bien conscience de la nécessité de
protéger les droits d'auteur je sais
aussi qu'un certain nombre de
difficultés proviennent des politiques
commerciales pratiquées par les maisons
d'édition et distributeurs privés mais
j'estime que l'état ne peut se réfugier
derrière de telles excuses pour
justifier un certain immobilisme
il se doit d'adopter une politique
volontariste afin de capitaliser sur les
nouvelles technologies pour faciliter la
diffusion de notre littérature française
contemporaine à l'étranger encore une
fois il ne s'agit pas simplement des
droits des consommateurs français à
l'étranger mais aussi de notre
rayonnement culturel et de nos intérêts
commerciaux si important
merci ma chère collègue la parole est à
monsieur benoît hamon mini chargé de
l'économie sociale et solidaire et de la
consommation
merci monsieur le président madame la
sénatrice joëlle garriaud-maylam
je vous ferai une réponse qui se
concentrera essentiellement sur la
question des obstacles à la
commercialisation des livres numériques
pour vous dire que la préoccupation qui
est la vôtre et qui est partagé par le
gouvernement est double il ya à la fois
dangereux en matière de diffusion
de notre patrimoine littéraire mais
aussi de ce que sont aujourd'hui les
différentes oeuvres qui sont édités en
france mais aussi un enjeu en termes de
consommation puisque defacto dès lors
qu'il existe des obstacles au fait que
l'on puisse télécharger des livres
numériques ce sont autant d'actes de
consommation en moins il a donc une
double problématique à la fois
culturelles aussi de transmission et de
développement la francophonie est une
dimension économique incontestable à
votre question à partir de laquelle avec
la ministre de la culture le
gouvernement vous propose les éléments
suivants d'abord vous rappeler que la
commercialisation des livres numériques
étaient encadrés par un ensemble de
règles auxquelles doivent se conformer
les entreprises qui distribue
aujourd'hui ses produits ces règles
peuvent avoir des conséquences sur
l'accessibilité des livres numériques en
fonction de la localisation de
l'acheteur ce que vous avez vous même
évoqué notamment les distributeurs
doivent impérativement respecter la
réglementation relative aux droits
d'auteur et sont soumis à des règles de
territorialité de la diffusion des
oeuvres numériques qui sont prévus dans
les contrats de mandats signés avec les
éditeurs le gouvernement qui est donc
attaché comme je voulais dit à la bonne
diffusion à l'étranger des livres
français y compris numérique veillera à
ce que le développement de cette
diffusion ne soit pas entravée par la
mise en oeuvre de restrictions qui
seraient injustifiés c'est la raison
pour laquelle au delà de la première
expertise qui a été réalisé par les
services de l'état sur les modalités de
cette diffusion des travaux
d'investigations complémentaires plus
approfondies sont envisagées de façon à
pouvoir permettre le développement de
ses ventes de livres numériques
au delà des frontières du pays sans
qu'il y ait d'obstacles de
discrimination à la shta à l'achat de
ces livres numériques c'est la autres
cas l'engagement du gouvernement je vous
remercie monsieur le ministre madame
garriaud-maylam
oui je vous remercie monsieur le
ministre de répondre à cette question
qui avait été initialement posée à votre
collègue fleur pellerin à l'automne en
sous une forme de questions écrites mais
à laquelle je n'avais eu aucune réponse
donc encore une fois je vous remercie je
connais bien évidemment ces obstacles et
c'est pour cela que j'ai tenu à vous
poser cette question parce que comme je
le disais dans ma question nous avons
vraiment besoin d'une politique
volontariste de la part de l'état nous
ne pouvons plus nous laisser dominer par
ces obstacles posés peut-être par
certaines maisons d'édition nous les
connaissons six obstacles mais nous
avons aussi la capacité d'aller de
l'avant et je voudrais rappeler que dans
le cadre du pacte transatlantique de la
négociation des accords de libre échange
la position de la commission européenne
est très clair et vous me permettrez de
la cité l'accord n'aura aucune incidence
sur la capacité de l'union et de ses
états membres à mettre en oeuvre des
politiques des mesures pour tenir compte
du développement de ce secteur on parla
de l'audiovisuel parce que là encore
monsieur le ministre nous avons des
problèmes beaucoup de télévision de
programmes télévisés ne sont pas
accessibles depuis l'étranger une
plateforme numérique a été mise en place
en 2010 la plateforme place mais
malheureusement les français d'étrangers
des étrangers francophones souvent n'y
ont pas accès et j'ajoute aussi que les
négociations
je cite là encore la commission
européenne devrait respecter le but de
préserver de développer la diversité
culturelle l'union européenne et les
états membres garderont la capacité
d'adaptation de la législation à
l'environnement numérique
donc une fois de plus monsieur le mini
jeux vous remercie mais je compte sur
vous pour essayer de donner un nouvel
élan à ces réflexions et surtout aux
actions pour que ses livres ses
programmes qui sont tellement importants
si nous voulons maintenir notre
francophonie si nous voulons développer
notre rayonnement culturel qui est un
enjeu économique extrêmement importants
les états unis l'ont compris depuis très
longtemps nous avons besoin de vous et
je vous remercie de ce que vous pourrez
faire en ce sens